I was trying to be on a health kick
and I bought. I bought it.
My money. I bought the mushroom coffee,
but I bought it from the TikTok app.
This is my review.
I wanna know some tips and tricks on how to make it taste better,
cause it just has.
Hmm. It's.
It's giving a little too much.
I do like,
it's 2,000 milligrams of mushrooms,
and it's shiitake, Turkey tail,
king trumpet, lions meal, rice,
you courtesy, it's all the good shit.
And then it does have instant coffee in it,
so it does have, like, caffeine,
like half a cup of caffeine.
But how are you ladies mixing it?
If you wanna try it, it is here in the TikTok shop.
And then maybe you could let me know how you're making it taste good,
you know what I mean?